the metaverse is coming
it's here
microsoft buys activision blizzard for
69 billion dollars in cash can you
imagine having 69 billion
uh in cash on your balance sheet or
being able to part with it and still be
a healthy company so this again is the
concern and it's been happening in tech
for years and years and years like you
just have this mega consolidation
happening uh trillion dollar companies
if i start a new tech startup in the
site i say hey i'm going to be the next
google like laughed out of the room yeah
left out of the room um but if you say
hey google's going to buy me for 100
million great idea yeah i'm listening
i'm listening um and then by the way if
you fail google buys you for tens of
millions just just for the talent
half the time yes yeah so somebody
worked on one of those yeah you got a
job at google it's like the show silicon
valley where you know like you reach a
certain scale like uh you know it
becomes
arbitrary
um you're playing with what tim o'reilly
calls uh super money
um and so
like it's it's almost impossible to
compete with super money that they the
laws of business physics stop applying
i'm not i'm a former you know small
private company operator like i'm and
you know this about me i'm like i'm
really acutely attuned to the laws of
business physics you know it's like hey
we gotta like you know
um like uh watch what we spend and try
and grow into it and do all this stuff
but like after you achieve
uh
orbit or liftoff then like none of that
stuff applies to anymore
[Music]
this week on forward an open democratic
primary in 24 why dems are frustrated
with joe biden microsoft making a big
bet on the metaverse buying activision
blizzard plus yang gang vintage merch is
back at andrew yang.com this week on
forward
[Music]
we are back welcome back from a
triumphant trip to buffalo i know it's
not a sports podcast but let's go bills
i'll say
we'll close we'll close on that
let's just say i'm in a good mood today
as is the entire city of buffalo i will
say if you turn on an nfl game uh and
it's whatever zero degrees there and you
know your friend drove six and a half
hours to be there then you're like wow i
really hope they win
[Laughter]
yeah man i've done the trip to buffalo
after losing and then and driving back
after and it's not fun so it's a very
very high variance experience
but the feeling feels so good when you
win though anyway we're back
happy thursday america
happy thursday uh and we are back with
some big political predictions i am
completely shifting gears zach
where i thought that it was going to be
a trump biden rematch in 2024
because i thought the democrats would
not want to have
a fractious
primary
in the face of trump but now i have
changed my mind i believe that the
democrats are going to open it up you're
so fake how dare you
you liar
i don't know i'm just pretending to be a
bad twitter troll that's funny i well i
got some
updated information uh that that has
changed my thinking but that's what is
that info well the single biggest
piece of information is how joe is doing
i mean it's really it's pretty obvious
yeah um where the deference within the
democratic party to him is plummeting
quick i was stunned that he showed up in
georgia
for a voting rights speech and stacy
abrams did not show up i mean it's
literally her issue
and it's georgia and it's the president
of your party
and you are running for governor and you
have a scheduling conflict i mean
georgia's not that big a state
you know
conflict like you could get there you
know and if you have a like an event
scheduled you could be like hey fyi
president's in town so you know we're
gonna reschedule and everyone will be
like oh yeah sure get that so that was
to me a massive
shock all you need to know
that is a lot of what you need to know
uh the other thing that happened was
that he went to the senate to give a
speech to the senators about
abandoning the filibuster for
uh voting
rights and election reform
and he gets there and then kirsten
cinema gives a big speech about how the
filibuster is going nowhere before joe
gets there
making joe's speech like a complete
non-event and then joe just ended up
talking off the cuff
instead to the extent that there's any
deference to joe it's just disappearing
very very fast so that's number one
number two is that i heard from a number
of
donors
that they are looking for an alternative
and so where the donors go you can be
pretty sure
the party and the candidates are going
to go right
because it's mainstream let's just say
they're a leading indicator and if you
have major donors who are going to their
favorite candidate hey i think you
should ready yourself for a run in 24
the candidate is going to start thinking
about it i mean that like they're trying
to keep it on the down low until the
midterms but i now believe this is
happening this is fascinating which is
going to make this podcast at least
politically more interesting so joe i'm
fascinated i'm always fascinated by how
these candidates brand themselves right
and so joe branded himself in 2020 as
you know joe
nostalgia restore the soul of america
restore the soul of america let's bring
the sanity back right
and which is a platitude essentially
which is a there's no real policy vision
there which is fine like i think a lot
of people were like yeah like we can all
kind of get behind this yep vanilla
return to normalcy right
and then
unless
he is my opinion unless you're proactive
on branding yourself with a vision of
what we're gonna execute on
you then just leave this void for
everyone else to define you right he had
a
mantra which is we're going to build
back better yes and then build back
better became this no one knows it is
legislative package
that ended up
failing that's another reason why you
can look at this and say okay
i think someone else is going to end up
the democratic nominee
i think he's going to
send signals and then
step aside is this kind of a byproduct
of the times getting so polarizing or is
it a leadership failure trump got that
tax cut passed and the republicans
quickly ish right yeah and the
republicans had congress so that was
their big legislative accomplishment the
democrats legislative accomplishment is
going to be this infrastructure act
right and there were some other things
that got passed too the covet recovery
act yeah
early on so there were like two big
bills
that passed part of it is the messaging
and expectation right there are a lot of
people i know
who are upset at this sense that the
democrats promised something and then
did not deliver the two big things that
stick out in my head that i've heard
directly from from black activists
actually number one is student loan
student forgiveness what the hell that's
easy yeah especially federally and
student loan forgiveness we should
discuss so it has gotten punted down the
road time and time again where if you
have student loans you have not had to
pay them
it was supposed to resume february one
bike out push back this year right yeah
that got pushed back to may 1. right by
the way these delays are so annoying for
people paying debt in the sense that do
i have to like if you're because you're
all you're all got this boot on your
throat and it gets lifted a little bit
you're like can i make a decision
it's gotten lifted now for the better
part of two years yeah that's true and
the odds of it actually kicking back in
in may strike me as vanishingly low okay
because if you're the dems let's see if
you kick the can down the road again
then you seem like you're
keeping your constituents in mind if you
have it kick back in you have
millions of people
resuming debt payments six months before
midterms
you know so
so at a minimum the dems will be like
and let's push this off again political
football for seven months until december
like that that strikes me as the most
likely outcome
but many people are ticked off that
biden has not done more to
forgive significant proportion or in
some cases all
of student loan debt the other big one
is voting rights and election
protections they've promised very big
things on that and not delivered there
are folks in georgia in particular who
feel afflicted because state rules
around this have changed and they feel
like the administration didn't do enough
and then when he came down to give this
georgia speech they weren't that pumped
about it and now they're trying to get
it done in the senate and they're two
votes short so those are the two things
that democrats i think have been
disappointed on and it's going to really
really hurt
enthusiasm later this year
[Music]
canceling student loans
the arguments on both
foreign against like one you've talked
about the boot like we've got a
generation of students now probably two
generation students with just massive
mass amounts of debt
you also have a bunch of folks that have
uh
work have worked or made life choices
and sacrifices to pay off their student
loans
and it would be
i don't know feeling short changed or
upset that they didn't get theirs for
free not that that is probably enough in
mass thoughts on how you do that
politically
in practice
how that mechanically works and maybe
even elaborate why you think joe hasn't
done it
i talked about this on the trail where
um i think student loan debt is out of
control uh and a lot of it wasn't
morally generated you're looking at 1.7
trillion dollars plus it's crippling the
ambitions of a generation or more i mean
it's not just young people too i mean
there are a lot of middle-aged people uh
and older
that have massive loads of debt
um is there a fairness issue uh between
people who still have debt and either
worked uh to pay that debt off over a
long period of time or
never went to school because they were
afraid of the debt like yeah there's a
fairness issue right um and in my ideal
world you would do something broader
like for example some version of
universal basic income and then be like
hey you know if you have debt you can
pay it off if you don't you know you
have money um like that that struck me
as more fair
um the problem right now is that there
there's no administration of being able
to distribute things to people that
don't have student loan debt and there
is a mechanism
where the president can potentially
forgive the student loan debt and it's
in a bit of a legal gray area but it
seems like it there's like a strong
argument to be made that he could
forgive the student loan debt um so then
if you're in a binary choice where it's
like hey i can forgive um some or all of
the student loan debt or do nothing
right um then in my mind
even with the fairness
issues like you should do something
because it's going to lighten the burden
for a ton of people it's going to
improve the economy it's like a fine way
to get buying power back into the
economy right um why is he not doing it
that that is a very interesting question
i think that biden has some innate
hesitance and conservatism around mass
debt forgiveness at this scale
one thing he said he would do is he'd
forgive up to ten thousand dollars per
person
um and even with that they're like okay
so why not do that and he's like well if
congress passes legislation for that
then then um then we'll do it uh of
course the odds of congress passing that
are zero so uh
so i i'm at a bit of a loss as to why
okay the reason why he's not just
writing an executive order saying i'm
gonna forgive ten thousand dollars in
student loan debt for everyone um is
that that probably wouldn't even make
anyone happy like there'd be a handful
of people uh that maybe only had ten
thousand in student loan debt but if you
had more then you'd be like keep going
like what you know what what
like what is this like and then people
who uh i were on the outside looking in
would be like what are you forgiving
their ten thousand for and not my car
loan or whatever you don't make the
people you're helping that happy and you
piss off the people would be pissed off
so for the record again my choice my
preference would be like broader relief
to everyone so it's like distributed in
a way that people can can be on board
with but if i had this choice and i was
in his shoes and i had like you know
just limited options i would forgive the
student loan debt yeah i would say so i
had like 180 to 200 grand
plus
in student loans
and i solve for that by selling my soul
on wall street and like i liked my it
was fine but it was not what i've would
have chosen right that's 10 years of my
life doing that right like on a personal
level you're like man i did all this for
something that the gunman just forgave
to everybody after i made this like life
altering choice
um
and i'm sure and millions of others have
as well but on the other hand there's a
difference between like what affects you
personally and what affects the masses
right and the reality is i just have so
many friends and family who are just
they suffer from it it's awful i also
had six figures in a student-run debt i
used to call it my mistress yeah running
a check that's how he may be i hope
you're having a good life
sally
i'm trying to figure out how many years
it took me to to pay that off
doing some math
i'm getting old
i got like nine for me eight or nine but
i like i would basically at wall street
i'd get a bonus since i would get like
some chunks now just pretend i'd live on
the salary and just pretend the bonus
didn't exist
um
but if you're trying to like live with
that and just chip away
i mean there's plans out there well you
just never get out of it yeah you're
just paying the interest it took me 10
years and a lot of good fortune
um uh you know in in my case
uh
i still had the the
debts until
um my company was acquired and then i
was like oh you know married yes i might
also just so in order to get out of
student loan debt you have to start
and sell like build a company yeah no
it's ridiculous right i don't have to go
get a job but when i was running the
company and just drawing a salary you
know like i was gradually paying the
debt down on like a 25-year timeline or
something
completely unrealistic for the vast vast
majority of student debt holders and
whatnot the way i mean the way to do
this is have it's and this has been
proposed not my ideas is that public
education if it's state-funded or
federal funded to educate public schools
like colleges universities
um
are free um or
you can do a whole bunch of like revenue
sharing agreements with companies
but in that way
i think there are certain degrees that
like you know one of the there's a lot
of [ __ ] in the end yes there's like
right in there private companies
charging you out the ass for degrees
that will never make you any money you
know what's the darkest zack is that if
you go to someone who's
uh issuing let's say questionable
degrees of questionable value yeah to
poor black uh students or latino
students or whomever or military
veterans or whatever vulnerable
population it is yeah which by the way
is what they do it happens all the time
yeah uh and then you go to them be like
hey like what you're doing totally
messed up they'll be like no i'm serving
this vulnerable underserved population
and it's a really wholesome mission and
like you know back off because if we're
not doing it then no one's doing it
and that's
for the most part uh [ __ ] you know
it's like if let's say you were a
non-profit
um like making that argument then i'd be
much more
uh open to it but the people who are
making those arguments are the most
shady for-profit schools that are
returning money to investors so it's
like look if you really cared about
serving military veterans or whatnot uh
why not forego like you know like your
massive investor returns like the profit
margins because the profit margins on
that stuff
are
often very high because they're
siphoning off the government yeah it's
it's some really dark stuff
[Music]
so voting rights is sticky it's tougher
because national democrats aren't as all
in on the whole voting rights package
that i think the voting rights activists
want to pass specifically
not being able to vote without an id is
a big hang up at one of the hang-ups
some of these go pretty far i always
thought it was kind of racist to assume
that the the notion is that people of
color can't get an id and that felt
racist and kind of belittling to me but
that might be naive help me understand
where the hang up is on voting rights
there's not evidence of widespread voter
fraud or people voting when they're not
supposed to
in
really just about any context
and so if you are passing rules to make
it more difficult to vote then you do
have to question it's like well why are
you passing these rules like you're
really concerned about it these rules in
my opinion go the wrong direction we
should be making it easier to vote not
harder to vote i agree with that i would
suggest that the single biggest
infringement on people's ability to vote
is that they have to vote in many cases
in closed party primaries and the
registration [ __ ] the registration
but you know those are actual issues
correct
no no one's talking about that and so no
one's up on that so we'll talk about the
fact that the mayoral registration
deadline in new york city the primary is
six months after the presidential when
no one's paying attention and the
registration deadline is six weeks maybe
a little more early yeah it's in
february four months ahead of time
yeah ridiculous so you have very strange
infringements that everyone's like
nothing to see here now i again think
that these state rules were passed for
partisan reasons yeah it's just a
partisan thing i'm a blue state in blue
city i keep more republicans out of my
election we keep it blue yeah i'm a i'm
a red state you know i'm going to make
it a bit harder for
people with you know frankly uh lower
levels of resources to vote that
overlaps with people of color like it's
going to increase my chance to win it
cuts the wrong direction it is part and
parcel with a lot of other things that
are happening in terms of redistricting
and gerrymandering that just the parties
play hardball
so this is a version of partisan
hardball that the the democrats are now
framing as much more deep and
fundamental than that um the there are a
couple of intersecting issues here is
that um a lot of these rules are being
adopted at the state level by republican
legislators
and
so members of congress are like hey
let's fix this now there are some things
i by the way completely agree with that
i would love congress to help address
like do i think that state legislators
should be able to fire and override
secretaries of state or certified
election results no so there are a lot
of things i agree with about uh the the
democrats uh efforts but they aren't
able to to get it done because they need
a few republicans or precisely 10
republicans to be on board with some
version of it
and this is something that i i believe
is is a strange
process choice by the democrats and i
believe it's because they want to
moralize and signal to their base
more than anything else as we're having
this conversation the senate right now
is proceeding on voting for
legislation that they don't have the
votes for mainly to put pressure on
kirsten cinema and joe manchin to have
to come up and say like hey i'm not for
this bill got it um now kirsten cinema
and joe manchin have said publicly i am
not for this bill if you put it up to a
vote i am not going to vote for it the
odds of them then having a change of
heart when the vote happens strike me as
zero because that's going to make them
seem like completely
wishy-washy they've already taken a
stand
and they've made a calculation or a
choice that either they think it's the
right thing or the voters are cool with
it
the only real path forward would be to
adopt something that the republicans are
open to at least a few of them there are
some noises that republicans are open to
something around the electoral uh count
act which is this really bizarre process
through which you know there's there's
some shades of gray as to how you
certify a presidential election result
so republicans are like hey
we'll look at that and there are some
other things republicans are open to now
like it or not you need a handful of
republicans or kirsten cinema and joe
manchin to get on board with with
something passing the problem right now
is that they're
going through these motions it's not
going to succeed in my opinion
and it's going to end up stiffening both
kirsten cinema and joe manchin around
this issue and maybe more issues because
you could theoretically resuscitate
parts of buildback better if joe manchin
and kerrison cinema got on board via
reconciliation so it's been a really
strange order of operations where they
were going for buildback better mansion
crashes it says hey i'm walking away
from this thing there was in my opinion
a glimmer of hope that they could try
and bring it back but then they said you
know what we're going to go to voting
rights voting rights or filibuster
reform or filibuster reform to lead to
voting rights
legislation and then manchester like hey
not on board with it either and now this
one cinema is like i'm not on board with
this either and on the filibuster there
are a couple of other democratic
senators were like i'm not sure where i
am on this um so uh so then you go to
this and let's say this fails which it
looks like it it almost certainly will
it will it will fail i'll say that
my hedge then they'll be like okay now
what do we do like go back to build back
better like after you essentially tried
to push mansion into a corner where
mansion will be like hey now that you
tried to shove me like uh over on this
filibuster stuff yeah now let's talk
about the the legislation that oh by the
way
now uh partisanship's picking up
midterms are inching closer uh like
people are starting to accept that maybe
this entire bill doesn't happen this is
a strange set of strategic choices on
the part of the democrats i think the
net results are going to be
disappointment um and i i'm not sure
why they made this set of choices
do you think it had anything to do with
appeasing the progressive wing of the
party i think a lot of it's for
appearance i think a significant number
of democrats are like look if we get
this to the floor and i say i voted for
it i fought for it and we can blame in
this case uh kirsten cinema joe manchin
then that's a better look for me than
this thing that's been ignoring you and
telling you it wouldn't have passed like
letting them be the bad guy interesting
so let's bring this back to the fact
that i think we're going to have a
relatively open democratic primary um in
2324 which is wild
uh the return to i or this is another
thing to talk about it looks like iowa's
still going to be uh very early in line
despite all the the the talk about
shifting order ridiculous yeah it's like
that you know
so it's going to be the return to iowa
new hampshire
nevada south carolina they might
reshuffle the order a little bit and so
the candidates are going to be back
um if you look at who's going to be back
probably or almost certainly some
combination of kamala harris pete butter
judge amy klobuchar i think all three of
them are running elizabeth warren has
been signaling she might run bernie has
said he almost certainly will not run
but who the heck knows
elizabeth warren may make the bet that's
like hey without bernie i absorb a lot
more and then i think you have some new
entrants um i i it seems that marianne
may run again but under the new entrance
i think you're going to have a couple of
governors joined the field
jb pritzker of illinois
just self-funded his upcoming
gubernatorial campaign for 90 million
himself his net worth is several billion
that we know of it's probably a bit
higher so if you have a political actor
who's willing to go
90 million in on a gubernatorial race
that you know like frankly i think he's
going to win like how deep would he be
willing to go for a presidential and if
you're the democrats and you're up
against trump who has like starts out
with like let's call it a 200 million
dollar cash advantage
uh you know is that appealing
um i think kirsten cinema runs for
president and i i can dig into that one
a little bit more dig on kirsten kirsten
cinema is a fascinating figure i saw her
speak and she is not to be
underestimated she is very very
confident and dynamic as a speaker in
terms of her background she's uh a super
marathoner she's got a very very high
level he's a data super marathoner they
run like 100 miles in the mountains and
[ __ ] she's a super marathoner um she's
bisexual uh i believe in i don't know
okay when you imagine someone who's
completely self-contained and
cool with themselves and
yeah give a [ __ ]
like could give a [ __ ] like what you
know you're saying to her on twitter or
whatever like could give a [ __ ] she
i believe is running she's positioning
herself now as something of this
moderate voice because now she's in this
uh anti-filibuster camp just for some
sort of institutional integrity by the
way establishment lane by the way i i do
disagree with uh with her stance on the
filibuster i think that uh i think the
filibuster is bogus i should blow it up
where yeah like the the it's made up we
all like it because when our party's not
in power it prevents in our opinion bad
laws from getting passed right and it
has saved bad objectively bad laws being
passed but
it also prevents most things from
getting done yeah and it's made up it's
just
that's part of it too it's a made-up
rule so i disagree with our stance on
that but uh i believe that she's
someone who can very easily
see herself as the leader that the
country needs uh and uh that there is a
need for a moderate independent voice
got it would you run as a damn or go
independent
would certainly run as a dem because
kind of the way bernie ran as a damn
right yeah and it's just a lot um a lot
more structured yeah a lot easier if you
run as an independent then you're into
problems though again i do believe that
there will be a third party candidate
that declares this year and so i am for
um you know obviously a challenge to the
duopoly but i don't think kirsten cinema
ends up taking that lane i think people
know this instinctively but don't always
say it out loud or put it front of mind
when it comes to presidential politics
it's all about the money it's all about
the money and there's three real lanes
for the money there's your traditional
donors just call it your establishment
and the wealthy traditional democratic
donors line up behind
they eventually line up behind one but
it's usually two to five candidates that
you know really get some noise there
then you have your populist lane which
is your crowdfunding lane um and some
people cross over like pete crossed over
decently well but that's like your
warrens your bernie's your you and then
the third one is if they self-fund
blueberg route yes the bloomberg route
i'm
i'm gonna make this call here i think
we're only a few
within 10 years i think i think an all
somewhat altruistic billionaire just
buys the damn thing
because with enough money you could buy
the whole thing you can bloomberg if
bloomberg get performed remotely better
he's our president right now because he
did none of the events none of the
cattle calls no iowa no new hampshire
just bought 500 plus million dollars in
ads in
the super tuesday states
and he was leading in the polls
their internal polls and a couple of our
internal polls had him
leading and he was in second now in the
public polls before that debate where
liz warren just took him to school
if he had performed adequately on that
debate stage i think he's our president
um so you have to be above to average
performer let's say average performer
but then you just buy the ads now you
have to have some sort of credibility
right you have to have some i don't
think you can be just a total clown well
he had a good resume obviously yeah he
was the three-term
right mayor of new york city yep so jb
pritzker is going to come in as the
governor of illinois um so he's
acceptable to the media and mainstream
throw steve bullock
throw cinema even with like you know
someone with a senator or governor
behind them and or in front of their
name
and a billion dollars that they actually
spend not tom stein the billionaire
putting some money in like actually
spending billions of dollars put in um
hundreds of millions low hundreds of
millions got it which is probably not
enough to do what i'm saying but also
steyer had no political experience on on
record uh 900 million damn
so you you probably a bill or two
yeah
if you if it was supplemented by
mainstream damn donors i mean mainstream
dem donors would obviously be a little
bit less motivated if you're a
billionaire because everything yeah you
you've got you could find yourself
but um but if you got nominated then
they would then they would do it just to
get access to you yeah and to try and
counteract trump right there's two ways
really to compete in the attention
economy there's relevance and volume so
relevant is like it's relevant to you
because you're passionate about it
people identify with andrew yang the
yang gang universal basic income people
are passionate about medicare for all
that stuff climate change whatever it is
um or just i identify with identity
politics that stuff
but
volume is the one where it doesn't
matter if it's relevant to you you just
get beat over the head with it over and
over right it's like why why does the
new york times retweet the same article
10 times a day whatever it is because
or why do you get emailed from target
multiple times for the same sale
it's that volume play and that's what
bloomberg was able to do no one really
like loved bloomberg but
he seemed credible he seemed like he was
going to win one of the interesting
elements of uh truly independent run is
that you don't need to go to iowa in new
hampshire yeah that's an artificial
construct yes as a result of the party
primary that's reinforced by the media
um but that that stuff is not
as impactful as it was
and i have a lot of friends in iowa new
hampshire but let's just look at what
happened here like how did joe biden do
in iowa
how did he do in new hampshire
yeah how did he do in in nevada also not
well
better though
that's what helped him the unions and
then it all turned around in south
carolina so if you
took iowa and new hampshire as
bellwethers
uh you would have thought it was bernie
or pete it seems like if you were to
run a campaign bloombergian style and
just be like you know what i'm just
going to saturate major media markets
i'm going to go crazy you know it's like
so it is
interesting how the democratic and
republican primaries are themselves
kind of losing their structure the
republican primary got overridden by
trump in 16. in 2020 the democratic
primary held together
uh now bernie tried to override it and
came close
i tried to override it and you know
i wanted to get a beer with that guy
very close yeah and the youth vote you
know i mean i i would fast out of the
fight like that i did not come close to
overriding the democratic primary yeah i
believe you're going to have
a number of candidates in each lane
um i think it's going to be a scrum as
to who emerges it'd be too soon to tell
but i i do foresee
some new candidates like kirsten cinema
and jb pritzker
uh being
very significant usually your bench on
these things if you're a party is your
obviously your congress members um
senators and your reps but all it's uh
your governors and strong mayors
and the problem is democratic big cities
and states have been
hurting badly la looks like a hot mess
san francisco looks like a hot mess uh
chicago not looking great new york
hasn't been great right the dem bench
isn't as strong as you'd like it to be
and i think we're going to find what's
going to be fun is that we're going to
find out how deep that bench is you know
what i'm saying yeah for sure we're
going to find out but i agree with you
that the governor is of the peace and
that's jb pritzker illinois that's uh
phil murphy in new jersey yeah it's
gavin newsom in california do you think
tulsi runs again
i haven't talked to tulsi lately i don't
have any insight uh yeah i don't know
i'm scared i'm it's gonna be say this
buckle up america for uh
2024 clown show and hopefully we get you
know someone who can defeat the donald
that's gonna be the big threshold
question again who can defeat donald
trump that was the question that we it's
going to feel like a rerun on the sequel
where you know the ending already yeah
oh man well do you know the ending i
mean on this one because joe eaked it
out he was facilitated by kovid
uh you know i it's it's a really really
open question whether whoever emerges
from the democratic primary is going to
be able to beat trump
this time yeah i'll tell you the ending
the ending is
a establishment democrat gets through
and gets stomped by the donald you have
to slightly favor donald trump i mean we
we don't know what economic
circumstances will be by then um but
certainly right now you know inflation's
high people are struggling people are
super discontent with the dems i think
the dems
as you said last week are going to get
wrecked in the midterms and then uh it's
going to be very hard for dems to feel
like they have positive momentum or
energy going into what will amount to a
re-election because even if joe's not on
the ballot people will be voting against
the party in power i also think
establishment dem gets kind of rocked by
desantis like does santa say we want
about him and you can say a lot but he's
going to go up there he's going to say
these masked mandates are stupid
open the schools
and we need to keep crime down
um and keep our streets safe and the
vast majority of americans are going to
say that the democratic contender is not
going to be able to say that i don't
think um because of the far left of the
party it would be interesting how like a
non-trump republican would fare but i
don't think we're going to have that
that is that that's the scenario you're
probably right
[Music]
we got big news
the metaverse is coming
it's here
microsoft buys activision blizzard for
69 billion dollars in cash can you
imagine having 69 billion
uh in cash on your balance sheet
or being able to part with it and still
be a healthy company uh microsoft so i
have visited microsoft's campus uh in
redmond have you
no it's like a [ __ ] city it is
massive
uh like microsoft is a mammoth
operation with an army of people
just as far as the eye can see in
buildings whatever building you're in
there's another building whatever campus
you're on there's another campus like it
dominates
that entire
you know area region
there was a time when microsoft once
declared a special dividend and it
literally like increased the size of the
local economy by you know fifteen
percent of that check like everyone just
ran and just like bought a house or
whatever like it was like a one-time
like they just said everyone who owns
microsoft stock we're gonna just like
give you
whatever it was
what's the what's the budget in new york
city 100 billion dollars yeah give or
take in that range right yeah so
they essentially bought a company for
70 of the budget in new york city just
for some rel like for some scale here of
how big microsoft is
uh
they're their own country i think um
yeah so they decided to throw down the
tune of whatever 68 69 billion for
activision blizzard and i have direct
experience with activision blizzard uh
do you zach have you played i've played
world of warcraft diablo starcraft call
of duty that's activision in it
i think it is activation i mean
activision is one of the biggest
publishers you can pick that up um so
it's called activision blizzard because
they bought blizzard which made the
games i just named
i played candy crush and i played call
of duty oh they own candy crush oh yeah
um so they own a lot
they're one of the big daddies in
gaming where
uh there were three big ones once upon a
time it was ea
activision and take two which made grand
theft auto
now geez like uh activision blizzard
becoming part of microsoft there's so
much heft i have to say that i loved
this move for microsoft okay that if
you're going to try and compete in the
metaverse owning
maybe the biggest gaming company in
addition to what you already have
with uh xbox um they own halo right yeah
the publisher of halo
which they bought for you know a lower
amount it's like i think 7 billion not
not that long ago
um so this is a massive move it's one of
those things where it's like a singular
target it's like there's not another
activision blizzard right you know the
so
i love this move for them it was a 25
premium over what activision's stock was
trading at it reminds me a little bit of
microsoft buying linkedin a while ago
uh for maybe i think it was like 26
billion or something like that yeah um
and linkedin is also a singular property
where like there's not another linkedin
so they said let's do it if you think
about people interacting virtually
gaming's uh
the biggest opportunity
uh something like linkedin might be top
five though
you know because you're there and you're
trying to
access professional networks and
guidance and the rest of it now what are
the downsides of this deal um what it
made me think of is that the small need
not apply at this point you know i mean
like if you imagine video game
publishing as this
like kind of wild westy industry and
then some like new publisher can come
and make a hit game right you can pretty
much toss that [ __ ] out the window it's
like you know it's like who's going to
be able to compete with
the resources of these mega corps or if
you did they'd probably just gobble you
up right like before yeah have you ever
made a real hit
like a candy crush or whatnot yeah then
they'd gobble you up right a take two
just bought zynga as well so the this
space is consolidating quick zynga owned
farmville oh yeah
draw with friends and uh in the early
days i was trying to gamify suit up
competitions and zynga was one of the
companies we're having conversations
with
it's hard to i mean we're learning with
remote schools the kids don't have that
yeah you know do you know the big
granddaddy player in the space that a
lot of people might not have heard of
no roblox oh yeah i've heard of them
yeah roadblocks like based upon i think
they're a little overvalued now but they
are well they might be the future
they're valued to the moon because who
the heck knows what goes on but i gotta
say if you use my kids
as any indicator proxy like roblox could
be valued at infinite because like they
that's that that is their metaverse yeah
uh oh wait we should look up roblox
freaking valuation because that's the
move like well that was i was debating
carl and i were debating like buying
this bad boy 44 billion market cap
trading at 75 bucks can you look at uh
up uh
facebook slash meta's market cap 900
billion
yeah so
if your
facebook slash meta and you see what's
going on uh like you think you know can
we get 110 billion to get together to
buy roblox or something like that and
you don't have that kind of cash on hand
but you can finance you can do a stock
for stock so i think that's the way this
world is going and so the mega
consolidation
is not a great look that there are a lot
of dynamics in tech that end up guiding
you towards a handful of mega companies
and i made this point of the debate
stage a while ago it's like how many
social networks do you want
like you don't want you want one for
your personal and one for professional
that's it yep no one wants to use bing
yeah how many search engines do you want
one how many navigation apps do you want
one like you just want one thing
and so imagining that you're going to
have you know seven competitors when
that makes zero sense in a lot of these
industries and that's true the metaverse
too how many metaverses do you want to
log into
one
like i want to go where the people are
where the things are where the cool [ __ ]
is um so you're
trying to figure out who actually owns
the metaverse what does it look like
one very significant
uh play would be you know what it is
freaking
starcraft warcraft
uh candy crush like all that stuff like
microsoft's that
uh another bet which by the way this bet
again according to you know what's going
on in my household roblox would be a
very very
big bet i'm actually going to call it
right right now
facebook buys roblox
or it's going to be a bidding war like
you're gonna alphabet buy as well i was
gonna say alphabet or uh or apple uh
alpha oh apple buys roblox i'm saying
like these guys are all gonna compete
for it
and
roblox may say
f you i'm gonna be bigger than you
that's like the best hope to dethroning
the big four right so so here here's one
of the problems if you're like the the
roblox of the world you have to interact
with them right oh no so this is the the
problem actually companies were at large
um so let's say roblox is a public
company which it is
um i don't know if they have those
special zuckerberg provisions where the
founder can say fu to everyone and just
do what they want
if they're a normal public company then
you have a board that has a fiduciary
responsibility to the shareholders to
consider whatever is going to maximize
the value so if uh apple comes in and
says hey roblox here's you know a 30
premium to your current by the way crazy
hyped up overvalued share price um like
uh then the shareholders the the board
members have to consider and take to the
shareholders uh you know you can't just
say if you were gonna you know keep on
kicking ass
um
you know you have to you you have to at
least consider it so i i don't know the
ins and outs of roblox's internal
governance um but
you know on the flip side of your roblox
and you look at it it's like like are
you going to take over the world maybe
one of the things that happens to a lot
of companies though is and this is the
activision blizzards rationale for
selling um is that they looked up and
said hey how are we going to be able to
compete ourselves
um at the highest level um to build the
metaverse it's like you know what might
help
a parent company with you know tens of
billions of extra money lying around and
you know like a giant business platform
and a giant this and a giant that um so
if you're roblox you look up and be like
hey you know what that might help
like a giant trillion-dollar parent
company with devices in everyone's hands
and like a set top box and you know in
the form of apple my issue my inherit
like my gut without being i don't think
anyone's technically an expert in the
metaverse it's not built yet but my gut
instinct on the metaverse is that the
problem
is someone has to build it and own it
and then we all have to rent or buy from
it right it's
if you're talking about building a whole
new world
uh we're at the you know like explorer
phase right where we're traver
traversing around new areas and either
building like we're finding areas that
if it's planet earth people are finding
new areas claiming them as their own
stealing them and then selling them for
profit right in this world facebook is
going to build said real estate and then
sell them for profit
and why does facebook get to do that
amazon buys right yes
microsoft big five one of them's gonna
go for roblox for sure
um
i don't know
if that's a good thing right where we
all have to buy from them so so this
again is the concern and it's been
happening in tech for years and years
and years like you just have this mega
consolidation happening
uh trillion dollar companies if i start
a new tech startup and decide i say hey
i'm going to be the next google like
laughed out of the room yeah left out of
the room but if you say hey google is
going to buy me for 100 million great
idea yeah i'm listening i'm listening
um and then by the way if you fail
google buys you for tens of millions
just just for the talent
half the time yes yeah so somebody
worked on one of those yeah you got a
job at google it's like the show silicon
valley where you know like you reach a
certain scale like uh you know it
becomes
arbitrary um you're playing with what
tim o'reilly calls super money
um and so
like it's it's almost impossible to
compete with super money that they the
laws of business physics stop applying
i'm not i'm a former you know small
private company operator like i'm and
you know this about me i'm like i'm
really acutely attuned to the laws of
business physics you know it's like hey
we gotta like you know
um like uh watch what we spend and try
and grow into it and do all the stuff
but like after you achieve
uh
uh orbit or liftoff then like none of
that stuff applies to you anymore
so a lot it's your point a lot of these
things we use every day are getting
consolidated right into these big tech
companies but they're still like these
small businesses that
google doesn't touch
facebook they don't touch because they
they really can't where it's your nail
salons and your your barber shops and
your small your law firms and
invest in banking a bit and they still
touch them but go on well yeah but yeah
but you know you can have a small
consulting business or xyz but i'm i'm
assuming in the metaverse
it just all goes through facebook right
it just all goes well it's probably
similar where you can set something up
and everything and then they just take a
toll they take a toll this is a dream
this is an exchange rate man
you had to like exchange living the
dream dollars for like meta bucks or
whatever
[Music]
these companies are racing to make more
and more content one of those things
that microsoft has said publicly record
number of scripted uh shows because
they're the streamers are competing yep
you know why why because the streamers
also don't have to obey the laws of
business physics anymore correct they
just so if you're netflix you're like
what's my valuation you know
like uh 100 billion yeah hundreds of
billions it's like what am i i'm gonna
spend on content this year like tens of
billions um what's that the show it's
like sure let's do it because like maybe
there's a chance that you're in the new
squid game
uh and you know i'm just going to make a
whole bunch of bets because uh that
becomes rational at that time
right microsoft had said you know one of
the reasons they bought
activision blizzard was their content
right like they
you own those franchises one you can
make movies off of them like would
people watch the call of duty movie
possibly right probably actually if it's
good um
and more and more games in the metaverse
that sort of thing the only reason this
is working is because we're demanding it
as consumers like we want it we crave it
are we craving i'm curious your thoughts
on why we're craving it are we craving
it because
we're craving because it's awesome bro
because it's awesome
because the rest of life sucks
like we're consuming more than we ever
had right people are i mean i don't have
the numbers up top my head but i have
seen them you have two or where there's
more gamers than people playing more
video games there before people are
watching more tv shows and consuming
more content than ever before is that
just cause it's awesome
or is there some deeper i'm obviously
kidding somewhat yeah um but but you
have trillion dollar companies spending
endless money on entertainments that are
algorithmically designed to appeal to a
maximal number of us
so
you know and there are let's say four
companies that are doing the same thing
look up and be like sure like i'll i'll
check it out i i
used to think to myself and maybe this
will provide people of themselves i
don't know
i i used to see new movies coming out
you know good bad whatever um but my
attitude was like if you spend enough
money on a movie i'll see it
[Laughter]
how many michael bay movies have you
seen i mean it's like that movie cost
like 120 million i could see it for you
know 10 bucks it's like oh that seems
like a better value than my seeing that
like other movie for 10 bucks um and and
so now you have the equivalent of like
100 million dollar movie coming out
every day you know it's like i look up
and be like ooh like over the holidays
like what what were my options to watch
on streaming um there were at least
you know five
hundred million dollar offerings uh that
i could just like pull on up you know
it's a cornucopia yes i watched
foundation on apple tv basement over 100
million on that thing i mean one it's
very good but two
the production quality is out of this
world like holy [ __ ] i'm watching like
deep space battles and i mean god knows
what um
and it looks real so i agree like on one
hand it's awesome this is the most
important thing it's foundation good
because i haven't seen it
i was like i'm a big a big fan big fan
and it's like wow yeah yeah yeah it's
like uh
i'm not see that's what i'm talking
about it's like i like sci-fi and
obviously i like expensive
production you would love this it's
really good and i still haven't even
gone to foundations because you know
i've been tied up with something else
i've watched over break i watched so i
watched what was the wheel of time yes
that was pretty good that's what i was
talking about with that
because i'd read those books yeah so if
you know so if i'd read those books you
make and do they spend over 100 million
on that oh yeah oh yeah for sure uh
i like that i see where it's going i'm
not sure um i ended up liking the
witcher
with uh did i watch that yes i did
probably a hundred million dollars yeah
yeah that was over hundred billion for
sure sure did do you do you like this
new andrew yang threshold it's like have
you spent over a hundred million i
should check it out i mean that's like a
pretty significant you're saying like
the roi on that i love the logic
[Laughter]
no no i'm obviously being half uh
facetious yes uh you know because like i
appreciate art and humanity and like
like creators and people doing uh stuff
but like if you know if you're a
timestar if you don't know what the hell
to do it's like yeah it's just like
but but but there's just like a flood of
content a flood of content we have this
amazing [ __ ] to watch at all times
but we end up
i have a feeling we're doing less like i
just don't see how sustainable this is
if
there's like this massive massive mass
of incentives for us to do nothing but
consume it's ready player one yes it's
metaverse it's really player one there
is some gendered element to it um
because you know there's a bit of a guy
thing around gaming and the metaverse
now i know trillion dollar companies
will be trying very hard to change that
they'll be like how are we gonna how do
we get the women yeah how are we gonna
do video games yes is this going to have
negative repercussions uh for family
society like of course and i mean i
think that that's pretty obvious
okay you know what i want to do next
episode we'll do this next step well um
my dad is pretty involved in men's
ministry growing up and i think i've
seen the
like the male side and the family side
of when men
neglect what's called other
responsibilities for god knows what but
i feel like gaming and getting addicted
to shows and things like that
is going to be a factor in that equation
and what it's doing to everything else
oh yeah
it's going to end up
making it harder for
boys to become men for men to form
successful relationships like i look at
this with my sons yeah i look at them
and be like how's this going to go and
one of my boys is autistic um and he's
going to struggle more right um
but there's something
frictionless about a lot of digital
environments
and i've been married now for 11 years
there's a lot of friction in a marriage
and and so if you're cultivated to
detest friction the most important
relationship in your life
has significant levels of friction then
you know are you going to make it
like over a multi-year period
uh so yeah let's dig into this next week
yeah i was talking to carly about this
she said both of and my parents too both
of her parents and my parents
it sounds like yours your i mean knowing
your dad came and your parents came from
uh taiwan
like they both made massive massive
personal sacrifices
to
be a father and a mother at least um for
the they're sacrificing their careers or
personal help or their own relationship
and things like that and she said i have
less of a desire to do that um and i've
my friends who have kids like similarly
like they're good parents but it's um
probably not the same amount of like
full-time commitment the way i feel like
my parents were like all in my parents
feel like completely selfless
like i like my my parents
subordinated any of their own personal
desires uh to try and create to raise
money for me same with my parents
and do you feel that same urge
for christopher and damian or do you
feel
maybe you can have it both ways because
things are faster and moving like that
or
maybe less so because society's more
built like i don't like you know i just
haven't felt that same drive and my
friends and peers
i have a a completely different outlook
than my parents because they immigrated
to this country and they were like we're
going to keep our heads down we're going
to make a living and we're going to try
and do what we can for our kids uh and i
actually took their sacrifice very
seriously where now i'm like hey i
should be thinking bigger i'm saying
what i do and like my impact because
otherwise
what was that for yeah what were the
sacrifices for now now what's happening
to my kids
um
is
tbd you know what i mean
you know
are they getting raised in a completely
different way than my brother and i were
raised oh yeah and like am i concerned
about it also oh yeah um you know yeah
so
uh you know like that and i try and
remind myself it's a different time for
different era
you know like we're like but
it's tough man i mean like i i
yeah like
everything tbd right it is totally it's
and it's not just
a little different it's the shawshank
redemption quotes like the world when
the guy gets out of jail and he's like
wow the world
went up and got itself in a great big
hurry like it we've accelerated the
change right so like
even being born 10 years apart now it's
like a different world right my sister's
six years younger than me and her high
school experience was fundamentally
different there was more smartphones um
so
i don't know and uh so let's we'll do so
next week guys we're gonna do um another
deeper episode i guess um
but um because i do think
unpacking this requires some research
and time which we need to put into it
but um it's more to come
i'm shifting gears
buffalo bills to the how great this vest
is right now yes bills at chiefs is
going to be the freaking game of the
season in my mind like i i think whoever
wins
that game
wins the super bowl they're probably
favorite sister bill you have to execute
right yeah because i i don't believe in
the tennessee titan sorry tennessee fans
uh i think the bengals have a fighting
chance to upset um the titans which
would give the bills or chiefs a home
field advantage against them if that
comes to pass i mean but i think either
kansas city or buffalo can go to
tennessee and beat the titans
so whoever wins
bill's chiefs goes to the super bowl
where they play probably the green bay
packers yeah or the bucks right or brady
you know in a warm weather stadium
that'd be a nice change
i'm gonna say this um and if you don't
care about football see you next
thursday go ahead fast forward um or
monday we'll be back monday um but if
you do or just find this hilarious or
you hate the new england patriots i just
want to tell you what i what just
happens i drove to buffalo it's zero
degrees okay
now for context the new england patriots
have been our big brother forever they
just beat us every time and what i'm not
exaggerating when i say that tom brady's
record against us was like
33 and two like it's ridiculous they've
just stomped us forever and
last year we finally beat them i was
like yay we beat them we won the
division hooray and this year we're like
we're going to keep going back there i
got a rookie quarterback don't worry
about it and we play them the pats are
doing pretty well they beat up like they
beat the easier teams on their schedule
first they went to buffalo and beat you
in that shitty game so they went they
come to buffalo i think their first afc
we're tied for the division and they
beat us in a it's a monsoon like yeah it
was a weird they threw the ball three
times we couldn't complete passes in the
red zone we had like four opportunities
to throw a touchdown past the end zone
we missed a field goal we lose by three
points and the pats instead of saying
hey our rebuild's working we've got a
young quarterback and like we're feeling
really good
they just start talking [ __ ] and the
national media's like patriots are going
to super bowl like google this like look
at what the national talking heads are
saying about the new england patriots
they're the best team in the su the best
bill belichick is a genius he's the
greatest coach of all time and it was
infuriating so then we get to play him
again in week 16 and we stomped them we
beat them by like multiple scores 45
josh allen looks great it's fantastic we
beat him on the road the pats loves the
division we win the division great and
then we get the playoffs and we have to
play the [ __ ] patriots again yeah and
everybody's like well this is the rubber
match this is where we're going to show
bill belichick's genius that last game
was a fluke and it's zero degrees it was
like josh allen can't play in weather he
can't play in the cold the buffalo bills
aren't good at home patriots have their
number and it's like oh my god if we
lose this game
it's all back to normal
and we go there
and we stomp them
it was 27 to 3 at halftime guys it was
20 it was 27 nothing for a bit and it
was
like 35 to 7 it was a blowout and
literally after half time it's just a
party
in buffalo how many people were there
seventy thousand people seventy thousand
people parked the party and people are
hugging
it's so like you have a beer it's frozen
the beer is frozen it's that cold right
so um
it's everything's frozen i had a thought
it took me like three days to throw out
like when you take a shower and still
feel like you're getting warmer but it
was
up there i've been to duke carolina
games in cameron it was up there with
that for sure in terms of experiences
might be once in a lifetime sporting
experience hopefully not because the
bills keep winning that's true but yeah
you go there and you beat the boogeyman
so guys exercise the patriots yes so if
you know a bill's family life give a hug
it's the greatest week of their life
this is great um
if you know a patriots fan
tell them to suck it because they've had
their i don't feel do not feel bad for
the patriots fans
they had their run and they talked a lot
of trash um
so yeah i'm feeling good now look we got
more to do gotta beat the chiefs um
but my prediction was a bucks build
super bowl uh so we'll see so we got to
beat him to do it the bills the bills
have that vibe man
i gotta say i mean you know you've got
sound special we'll see your lord and
savior josh allen special guy my my
brother
uh watched that game and hadn't seen
josh allen playing he was like who the
hell is this guy he threw a perfect game
let's see seven possessions seven
touchdowns the first time in nfl history
that a quarterback has not punted thrown
a pick he's kicked
he's amazing and it wasn't just the
throws too he can freaking run you can
ride
rolling and you know like quarterbacks
when they run
um they seem to be a little
worried about getting hurt leery of
contact yeah and like you don't sense
that at all from that guy and he lowers
his shoulder which is not good in the
long run we don't think that's because
he's we just want to work we just want
one soupy man just one more just give me
one
it's going to be such a big game it'll
be fun so you got bills chief 6 30
tonight or sixth tonight i wish 6 30
sunday night uh
if you at me on twitter at zack growlman
zack underscore groman i've got under i
got zach grauman and i forgot the
password and the email it's a hot mess
um so i own both but at sac underscore
grauman i will be biting my nails too
much but it will be a fun game that's
going to be crazy man you're going to be
freaking
freaking nervous as oh yeah very nervous
um it'll be fun but anything exultant
super happy it'd be great you're not so
i need to mention this because the yang
gang knows this you're not allowed to
make sports predictions about the bills
too late on twitter don't tweet it dude
don't do it don't do it
too late that curse is broken too yeah
we don't believe the curses around here
awful um and which is hilarious to me
because you like you're pretty good like
you're pretty insightful about sports
like you want when you went on the trail
we're taught in sports i feel like you
watch a lot of sports especially
basketball and they just every time you
tweet about something it just goes the
other way uh not every time but uh i
lost some coin
so you're not allowed and so i have
bills fans in my mentions like pretty
often i don't read all my mentions but i
do read some especially if they're
buffalo related and they're like don't
let yang pick the bill zach so here we
are you andrew and i'll do it just say
go both i respect superstitions i do uh
so on on my side to close it out i just
got back from houston texas uh the
forward tour and it was dynamite i had a
blast i i want to go back to houston as
one of those
types of trips cool but we are launching
some yang gang swag
uh to the world and i when i go out uh
there there are people with uh math gear
who are like hey like i'm trying to get
a new one i'm trying to upgrade and
whatnot um so it's now available at
andrew yang.com uh because of pent up
demand so if that describes you or
something in your life check it out yeah
until next week let's go buffalo until
next week let's go bills see you guys
[Music]